I wish I would have learned this in
school
think about a circle as infinitely many
rings of concentric circles
unwrap the outer ring to a straight line
segment
the length of this line segment is the
circumference of the original Circle
now continue unwrapping all of the other
Rings into straight line segments
the resulting shape has exactly the same
area as the circle and this shape is a
triangle with a base that's equal to the
circumference and a height that's equal
to the radius so the area is equal to
one-half times the circumference times
the radius which equals one-half times
two pi r times R and that works out to
be pi r squared so the area of a circle
is pi r squared
amazingly this was discovered about A
Thousand Years Ago by Rabbi Abraham Barr
hia hanasi amazing